Jennifer Aniston tells her pal Chelsea
Handler she may be returning to the
small screen comeback to come become to
net player so all over that that is
something because television is where
it's at I mean I really do believe that
the shows are more interesting there's
opportunity for women but brace
yourselves
plans fans didn't explain to I TV host
Lorraine Kelly why a show reunion
wouldn't work I don't know what we would
do I think that period of time was sort
of nostalgic friends ran for 10 seasons
before going off the air in 2004 you
don't want to see this to you
Hellyeah Anacin who played Rachel Green
on the hit series says a reboot in
today's society
what is resonate with viewers the same
and I think why people have such an
affection for it is because it was a
even though it was only 12 years ago it
ended or third yeah yep move farther
away there was something about a time
that where we didn't have we our faces
weren't shoved into cell phones and we
didn't we weren't like checking
Facebook's and instagrams and we were in
a room together or at a coffee shop
together and we were talking having
conversations having conversations I
know
we've lost that the 47 year old actress
and wife 2 justin theroux also gets
candid about the pressure society puts
on women to be married with children
again we're seeing women through that
very narrow lens of what we reduced down
to just something that's if we don't
have a baby or white picket fence or a
husband then we're then we're useless
and where are where we aren't living up
to our purpose
[Music]